[Música]
bienvenidos al programa de medio
ambiente de france 24 que una semana más
llega ha producido y grabado desde casa
le bastaron unas horas a joe biden en la
presidencia de eeuu para revertir varias
de las polémicas decisiones que
podríamos calificar de anti ambientales
que tomo donald trump en sus cuatro años
como presidente la más importante en
términos internacionales la de
reintegrar al país al acuerdo de parís
que es considerado el tratado ambiental
para combatir el cambio climático más
relevante hasta el momento ya que fue
respaldado por casi todas las naciones
del mundo la vuelta de eeuu significa
que el segundo país con más emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero en términos
absolutos está de nuevo dispuesto a
hacer algo para reducir su huella y
hacer que sea más factible si bien aún
muy complicado alcanzar la meta acordada
en 2015 de mantener el calentamiento
global por debajo de los 2 grados
centígrados con respecto a la
temperatura del planeta a finales del
siglo 19
le dio tanta importancia a este hecho
que la vuelta al acuerdo de parís fue el
tercer tuit que el presidente escribió
desde su cuenta oficial y fue la tercera
orden ejecutiva que firmó en el despacho
oval todo un giro de 180 grados con
respecto a su predecesor que también a
punta de decretos deshizo muchos de los
avances en materia ambiental que había
dejado la presidencia de barack obama
tanto es así que la universidad de
columbia en nueva york había creado un
rastreador para llevar las cuentas de
las desregulaciones ambientales de
donald trump pero el 20 de enero de este
año rebautizaron la página web en un
guiño a lo que esperan que haga la nueva
dupla en la casa blanca el rastreador de
regulación del clima identifica los
pasos tomados por la administración
válida en harris para restablecer y
expandir medidas federales de mitigación
y adaptación al clima que fueron
eliminadas durante los cuatro años
anteriores así como nuevas políticas
para abordar áreas no reguladas del
derecho climático aún le queda mucho por
hacer a bailén en materia ambiental para
que eeuu pueda sentirse orgulloso de su
papel en la lucha contra el cambio
climático pero
noticia ha sido bienvenida desde ese
primer día en la presidencia por la
comunidad internacional y los mensajes
siguen llegando varios líderes
reforzaron su bienvenida durante el
primer evento ambiental desde la
posesión de yoga y denny kamala harris
la cumbre sobre la adaptación climática
celebrada virtualmente con países bajos
como país anfitrión en esta john kerry
que fue secretario de estado bajo el
mando de barack obama puedo hablar por
primera vez de manera oficial como el
enviado especial de la casa blanca para
el clima
en orden hace tres años los científicos
lanzaron una advertencia bastante cruda
nos dijeron que teníamos 12 años para
poder evitar las peores consecuencias
del cambio climático ahora sólo quedan
nueve años y lamento que mi país haya
estado ausente durante tres de esos años
volvemos quiero que lo sepan con la
humildad por nuestra ausencia de los
últimos años y haremos todo lo que esté
en nuestras manos para compensar la
tenemos la intención de hacer todo lo
posible para asegurarnos de que la con
26 resulte en la acción climática
ambiciosa en la que los mayores emisores
aumente sus ambiciones de manera
significativa y en la que ayudemos a
proteger a aquellos más vulnerables
simplemente no hay manera de adaptarse a
un mundo 3 o 4 grados más calientes
excepto para los más ricos y
privilegiados
el evento en el que participaron varios
líderes mundiales además de la actual
secretario general de las naciones
unidas antonio guterres ha sido uno de
los primeros en centrarse más que en las
causas del cambio climático en sus
efectos y cómo adaptarse o mitigar su
impacto un impacto que según uno de los
expertos en adaptación climática del
instituto ambiental de estocolmo nos
afecta a todos él lo describe como un
efecto dominó ya que estamos todos
conectados y lo que pasa en una parte
del mundo tiene un impacto en lugares
bien distintos
guterres pidió que la mitad del
presupuesto para el clima se dedique a
la adaptación qué significa esto pues
entre otras cosas por ejemplo construir
más espacios verdes en las ciudades o
instalar sistemas de recolección de agua
lluvia para evitar inundaciones también
tener mejores sistemas de alerta de
tormentas o edificios y carreteras más
resistentes a estas todas estas opciones
podrían ahorrar en daños que en términos
económicos cuadruplicarían el costo de
implementarlas pero para esto hace falta
financiamiento hasta el momento el
presupuesto es de tan sólo un 5 por
ciento del dinero reservado al clima
cifra muy lejana al 50% que pide la onu
y con lo que coinciden expertos en la
adaptación climática en este sentido el
fondo monetario internacional anunció
varios cambios en su actuar que denotan
la importancia que le están dando al
cambio climático como un potencial
riesgo a la estabilidad económica
mundial el fondo monetario internacional
está poniendo el cambio climático en el
centro de su trabajo integrando al clima
en nuestras evaluaciones económicas
anuales vigilando los riesgos a la
estabilidad financiera relacionados con
el clima dándole más peso al clima en
las capacidades de desarrollo de cada
país y haciendo que los datos climáticos
sean parte de los principales
indicadores macroeconómicos
la directora del fm y kristalina
georgieva además recordó que construir
resiliencia es bueno para la naturaleza
y los ecosistemas para el crecimiento
económico para la creación de empleos y
para la salud y precisamente hablando de
beneficios para la salud
todos sabemos que pasará algún tiempo en
el campo reduce el estrés y a los que
vivimos en las grandes ciudades nos da
la oportunidad de respirar aire algo más
puro y soportar menos ruido pero el
campo no está exento de sonidos
sí
y estos sonidos por lo menos en francia
ahora forman parte del patrimonio
sensorial del país esto de acuerdo a la
ley aprobada por el senado francés una
ley que llegó al legislativo tras varias
denuncias contra gallos y patos hechas
por citadinos que iban a pasar el fin de
semana a su casa de campo y que sentían
que éstos cantaban obras daban demasiado
alto a partir de ahora el sonido de la
cigarra el olor a heno el del estiércol
o el redoblar de las campanas de iglesia
están protegidos por ley con imágenes de
la campiña francesa nos despedimos estos
france24
[Música]